will Mark fergus's new Stargate series
still respect Canon or do something
completely new welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
So Yesterday side Trek once again
dropped the news first that there was a
big development in the universe of
Stargate and that Mark fergus's penguin
in a Parker company has won the race to
be able to produce the new series Mark
Fergus will be the new showrunner now a
lot of people are extremely excited by
this but some people are a little
nervous and the main thing that seems to
be causing nerves is whether this will
be a hard reboot or a continuation of
the story we love well I have actually
been telling you for well over a year
Amazon always seemed to have a plan and
they seem to want to follow something
along the Star Trek model where it'll be
a sort of hybrid of Canon so my
understanding is that when Amazon put
out the call for people to pitch to
Stargate they basically said that they
needed to respect the Canon from the
series of sg1 SGU and SGA but with a
small caveat they would allow a certain
element of modernization and they would
allow a certain element of creative
freedom with a new story
so what does that mean well basically
that means they are going to be allowed
to change some stuff when I say the Star
Trek model I mean in that the new series
will stand alone in lots of ways they
will be allowed to have maybe a slightly
different style to the what we're used
to but to be honest SGU was very
different to SGA and sg1 so that isn't
really a major problem as far as I'm
concerned
don't forget to like subscribe and share
the video with all of your other Gator
friends also you go to side
hashtrack.com for brilliant Stargate
related merged just like this you can
even buy socks and anything else you
want please also don't forget the
Sidetrack sides Channel all the links
are in the description
but also you have to remember that this
is going to be on a streaming service
which is just completely different to
what we had back in the day so before we
had 22 Episodes their budget was quite
limited and they really relied on
syndication to make any money
in this new series however we're going
to get to see hopefully a much bigger
budget than what we used to but we will
only see probably 10 or 12 episodes per
season but what we might get to see is
two or even three seasons a year so if
we're lucky and this is successful we
might actually get to see a few
different stories and a few different
iterations of Stargate running together
a little bit like what Disney's done
with Star Wars where actually there's
only ever a couple of months between a
new Star Wars season we might get to see
something similarly with Stargate now
there is a big advantage of that it
means we get Stargate pretty much all
year round instead of just a big solid
you know five months of style getting
there nothing for the rest of the year
so and that respect I'm quite excited if
again this is successful so in that
respect this new series is going to have
a slightly different style it's a
completely different format and that is
going to show on screen in lots of ways
though if it's a bigger budget what we
see on screen should be a lot richer
maybe a lot better we're talking much
better special effects Etc but it is
going to feel different and I do have to
inject a little bit of reality into this
now a lot of people are saying they want
Brad right back they want exactly the
same sort of series as sg1 and if it's
not the same style then they just won't
watch it now I'm a little bit
disappointed by that I think you're
judging something before it's even been
officially green lit never mind made
and I'm just hopeful that we get
something that honors the original
series but at the same time is sort of a
modern take on that because audiences
have changed and the Stargate series I'm
sorry it just cannot be aimed solely at
Gators it cannot be aimed solely at the
fans that exist now me and you watching
these videos it's got to if it's going
to be successful attract a new audience
as well now they're going to very much
have that in mind when they're creating
this TV show so if you sit down to watch
the new Stargate series and all you're
thinking about is sg1 you are going to
be disappointed
but if you sit down excited to see a new
Stargate series something fresh
something that respects the original
Canon but maybe does it in a slightly
new way then hopefully we'll get to see
a product that we can all be really
excited about and all share now don't
get me wrong not everyone's going to
love the new Star game it's just not
going to happen
like not everybody loved SGU SGU is very
much a Marmite sort of TV series for you
know Gators people either love it or no
not so much so that's going to be the
same but we have to give this series a
chance it like I said they've got a long
road ahead it hasn't even been
officially announced yet but still a lot
of people are already saying they ain't
gonna watch it which just uh disappoints
me but what I'm actually being told
about what Mark Fergus plans to do in
respect to Canon now for one if you look
at a lot of things Mark Fergus has done
in the past and actually Matt's going to
do a video on Tuesday where he does
exactly that he does seem to respect the
audience and he does seem to respect the
Canon he with the expanse was very
careful about respecting the original
content if you look at what he did with
the Iron Man I would say it's very much
the same
so I'm not too afraid of that now like
in Iron Man and like in the expanse he's
not afraid to do something quite Brave
either so again quite exciting but he
has been given a creative license by
Amazon to make certain changes this is
why he did the content Bible and why
Amazon have worked alongside him to do
the content Bible for the new series
they have very very strictly been able
to say what you can change and what you
can't and there are certain things that
just will not be changing for one
Star Trek example again changing the
Klingons always pissed me off it's just
wrong and they shouldn't do it my
understanding is that key points of the
original Stargate series will not be
allowed to change the gold world will
still be the gold the replicators will
still be the replicators even though we
might see slightly different iterations
of things like the replicators but to be
honest we saw that June sg1 they evolved
they changed we will not see completely
new makeovers for these series for
example the whole Egyptian thing is
still going to be there they're not
going to just eliminate something that
really is key to the original series now
obviously none of this has been written
yet none of this has even been I mean
the development is barely even started
so we really don't know which way Mark
Fergus is going to take this just yet
but as I say my understanding and
conversations I've had over the last 12
months is that Amazon really are
respectful towards the TV audience
Roland Emerick told us himself in an
interview about six months ago that
Amazon only cared about the TV audience
so I think we can safely say that they
even though we might see some creative
differences are not going to do any
wholesale changes they are not going to
do a hard reboot and everything that
happened in sg1 SGU and SGA still did
and the return of certain characters is
almost guaranteed I can actually tell
you right now that I know for a fact
that Michael Shanks and Amanda Tapping
have already had conversations and are
very open to returning to Stargate maybe
only in small parts but they will return
now those conversations with Brad Wright
included Richard Dean Amberson now as
far as I'm aware Richard Dean amson has
not been approached by Amazon about
returning yet but that doesn't mean he
won't
so guys get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you think what are your
fears about the new Stargate series what
are you excited about and what are you
hopeful for let's have a bit of
positivity let's start bringing the
Gated Community together we don't need
any more cynicism we don't need any more
fear we just need to look forward to
Stargate being back on our screens
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you enjoy the content please consider
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
and hitting the join Button as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]